[Music]
[Applause]
pat ford is set to join us the sports
illustrated senior writer
he has been on hand for all seven of bob
baffert's kentucky derby wins
he wrote a column and his latest column
says this
to start out when it comes to drug
testing in sports the denials are always
vigorous
uh often fanciful but rarely compelling
the positive drug tests keep
piling up for bob baffert's top horses
so do the explanations
for them the dog keeps eating the
homework
an entire semester's worth by now with
permanent damage
to the digestive tract pat joins us now
walk us through the accusations here pat
uh well dan medina spirit surprise
winner of the kentucky derby
a sample of his drug test was positive
for beta methazone uh a uh
an anti-inflammatory slash uh you know
pain reliever sort of
sort of drug uh 21 picograms not a big
number
but a positive is a positive and this is
now the fifth time for bob baffert in a
relatively short period of time that one
of his top horses
has had a positive test uh the b sample
still hasn't been tested so we'll wait
to see what comes back with that if it
is
positive then he will be disqualified as
the kentucky derby winner just the
second
drug positive dq for a winner in derby's
in the derby's 147 year history this
drug is
legal in kentucky correct
yeah uh but it's not supposed to be in a
horse's system on race day
it can be used the the regulation
basically is that it
needs to not be used within 14 days of
race day i don't know why they don't
test these horses
right before on race day do do they
because it's 14 days
out and then do they test and then we
don't get the results till after the
race
i think that's the case here is that the
test was done
you know whether it was after the race
or whether it was right before in the
paddock i i'm not
quite honestly i'm not sure when
precisely the test was performed
it was it was a race day test i am
reasonably sure yeah but that's what i
don't understand
it's like justin turner tested in the
world series
prior to a game and then they took him
out in like the seventh inning because
they're like whoa
you you you tested positive i don't
understand why
they wouldn't test get results then that
way you clear the horses then you don't
nascar does this pat you have to pass an
inspection before the race
yeah right i get you i i just dan i
don't know whether they can turn it
around quickly enough to get something
that's close enough to the race to say
he's going to race clean you know i mean
if if you test him on
uh friday you could do something to him
saturday morning that could have an
immediate effect
on race performance so you know how long
it takes to turn around the testing i
think would be the the lag time there
would be the issue that you're uh
that kind of confuses what you're
getting at uh
all right give me bob baffert's
explanation here
back it says they never gave the horse
that drug period
he doesn't know how it got in this
system why is this happening to me
was part of his explanation and look i
like bob baffert i have covered him
since the day he arrived in churchill
downs as a nobody in 1996 i
again have covered all six or all seven
of his derby wins
he's like the me the best thing that's
ever happened to the media in horse
racing because he's so glib
approachable and available and
successful
but the explanations just stop adding up
again this is five
major positive tests or big time horses
in big time spots
and it says this is a positive test for
a drug that uh
his star philly gaming was positive for
on oaks day in 2020 so
he may have not put the the drug in the
horse but this is not a new drug
found in a bob baffert horse on a test
pertaining to a race
and we saw this with bounty gate with
sean payton he wasn't
involved in bounty gate but he was the
head coach during bounty gate he got
suspended
lost eight million dollars in salary
here
how much does i mean it's bob baffert's
stable his horses
you know could something somebody else
there on the food chain
yeah do something i mean it's possible
and you know he's basically was
intimating that you know is this
sabotage because a lot of people don't
like him which
i think is is again very fanciful uh
you know bafford horse of bafford derby
and
[Music]
pat's feed just froze up there
blame bob wow yep all else fails blame
bob
baffert